[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of the sun harry cole and the
political editor of the delhi mira peppa
queerer with us from now until just
before midnight welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then we're
starting with the metro which has the
big news of the night businessman elon
musk poised by twitter
for an estimated 35 billion pounds
the ft's international edition also
features the news about elon musk and
twitter but leads with word of panic
buying in beijing over fears of a new
lock down there
delhi mirror reports on the story of the
four people who were stabbed to death at
a house in south east london with the
headline bloodbath
lockdown and social distancing have been
linked to a surge of hepatitis cases in
young children that's on the front of
the telegraph
the guardian says the health secretary
is being encouraged to relax the law to
allow pharmacists to amend prescriptions
if there are shortages of medicines such
as hrt
and on the front of the sun pubs will be
allowed to stay open longer during the
queen's platinum jubilee weekend
quick reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out this front pages while
you watch us still a few to come in i
note uh well harry cole and peppa kura
are here and let's kick off shall we
pippa with uh twitter the breaking news
of this evening the world's richest man
with an agenda on free speech buys tech
um quite a shake-up i guess
yes it's a big moment isn't it i mean uh
harry and i are amongst those
journalists who spend quite a lot of
time on twitter um so it's gonna be
interesting to see how it changes in the
in the weeks and months to head now elon
musk the world's richest man has
obviously had his eye
on the social media platform for some
time he's tweeted in the past about uh
being interested in buying it and in
recent weeks we have seen
uh is sort of a gradual takeover bid
which at first was resisted by the board
they issued a poison pill to prevent the
takeover but they seem to have come to
an agreement now and that deal is now
going ahead and now musk is as you know
a fairly
uh fairly idiosyncratic character and he
has in the past uh used twitter to um to
sort of make his case for free speech i
think the big question that everyone's
going to be asking is whether that that
desire to reinstate uh what he regard or
he regards to be in state free speech on
twitter will mean
allowing donald trump back onto the
platform he of course was banned last
year um for inciting unrest at the
capitol
uh on the platform and uh it'd be
interesting to see whether
elon musk will put into practice his own
his own sort of desire for expanding
that free speech by by a lot longer
blocking some of his critics for example
journalists that have written rather
critical things about his companies or
indeed him so it's going to be really
interesting time for those of us that
use twitter regularly to see what
changes are going to be coming down the
line yes and from a business point of
view um everybody's kind of asked over
the years why has twitter not ground not
grown to facebook-esque proportions
harry and there's something about the
future in elon musk is there not you
know his companies his ideas you know he
sees things possibly that others do not
despite some of those criticisms as we
heard from her from pippa so what could
he do with it
well if the house is derision tonight
from the
majority of twitter users of the left um
are they going absolutely bananas
tonight it's absolutely fantastic and
there's talks of mass walkouts that
could make it all a bit more of a
bit more of a pleasant place to be
around there's been some interesting
suggestions that elon musk has made one
he will make people on there accountable
he's promised a red twitter of anonymous
trolls and you have to authenticate
yourself if you want an account now
pippa and i will both know you anna and
lots of anyone that appears on any form
of television radio or puts their name
in print we'll know that anonymous
trolls are you know the sewer of cesspit
of social media is never far away so if
you can come up good come up with the
goods on that then i can only be about
only a good thing however there's this
view with elon musk he's the wrong sort
of billionaire he's the wrong sort of
success story because he's leading to
the right uh slightly libertarian has
endorsed um donald trump not endorsed
donald trump but been
more than supportive than others of
donald trump you know there are screams
that um this is outrageous i've just
been quite amused by the reaction
tonight because when he first when
donald trump was banned from twitter
everyone you know all these lefty
commentators in america all screamed
well you know it's a private company
they can do what they want if you don't
like it you can leave and now they don't
like the owner of it they're suddenly
suggesting that somehow twitter should
be bought into public ownership as some
sort of global forum
owned by the people and you can't have
these things both ways you've got to
you've you gotta pick and choose these
battles and uh they they trying to have
their cake and eat it i think tonight
yes that fear of cesspit twitter
returning takes us to our next story
which is in the metro
um what happened over the weekend to the
deputy labour leader
comments today by boris johnson after
this uh mail on sunday article uh your
thoughts on this pippa
yes well we've seen widespread
condemnation of the uh
thrust of the article the anonymous
comments from a tory mp about angela
arena fairly sort of sexist
summon the editor of the mail on sunday
the newspaper that this article
appeared in um to speak to him about uh
about it uh he's obviously not very
happy about it either
um but you know i think that well
there's a couple of things i'd say one
is that
there's a feeling certainly amongst
journalists that we shouldn't the
journalists in general shouldn't be
punished for reporting what mps are
saying and that it's very important
often that we have the capacity to
expose what's going on and what people
are thinking without the fear of their
past is being taken off them or or being
censored um but uh but secondly i think
that newspaper is obviously a
responsibility to think about how those
stories are told
and i think any of us would agree that
the way that that particular story was
told was not uh sensitive indeed it was
it was very offensive um particularly to
uh mrina herself but also to women mps
across the commons more generally
and i think that
you know there's a feeling that that
story could have been told in another
way you know angela and broads in a in a
sexism scandal and perhaps being more
critical of some of the words um
that were issued by this anonymous story
mp but um you know i think that
journalists political journalists will
be watching this quite carefully because
you know it's potentially a slippery
slope well it's one thing that speaker
making his displeasure known to uh you
know standing up for mps making his
displeasure known to the editor of the
national newspaper i think that they
need to be quite careful that they that
they don't aren't seen as some might see
us to overstep the mark um and uh
you know stop and stop journalists being
able to report on some of this stuff
this isn't what the metro's got into the
metro's obviously got into sexism more
broadly in the comments but i'm sure
harry harry will have some views on that
well let's ask about the specifics of
this as well because the the person who
wrote it uh was the person who succeeded
you in the role i understand is that
right and um
not quite not quite um don't know about
you talking about sunday that's no
secret and used to work with that team
it's a brilliant team of professional
journalists i think they probably got
this one
um
wrong as pippa said there's always a way
to tell a story it's the presentation of
it i think that upset a lot of people
that said i totally i totally agree with
pippa that
it is not for politicians to decide who
who and how
uh stories are covered yes by all means
as everyone from the prime minister
downwards done
um today and yesterday make your views
known
but when you start hauling in editors
and you know you get into a as people
said a very slippery slope very quickly
of that role were between the false
estate and and and politics that needs
to remain in it needs to remain
combustible
yeah the mac cartoon goes with this
doesn't it front page of the telegraph
as well angela rainer most tory mps are
still distracted by the statue of lady
thatcher not sure that's quite true on
any level to refer but anyway but the
the point being made i suppose that it
puts women off entering house of commons
and it's not the first time we've heard
you know elements of sexism misogyny or
whatever however you want to describe it
um pippa just just quickly on this one
then you know how do they move forward
uh really in terms of treatment of women
etc
i think the single biggest way is to
call it out and it's not just for the
women in parliament to call it out it's
also the men the high-profile
journalists like harry but also the
senior politicians like the prime
minister and the speaker to make it
clear that it's not acceptable um to
address that sort of misogyny and hatred
towards women but also not just what
they've done publicly but also what goes
on behind the scene and scenes and
there's all sorts of allegations being
investigated by the communist
authorities uh about sexism and about
bullying and in some cases sexual
assault
and the commons is still in the process
of getting its processes in order
they're not there yet i think there's a
feeling generally that they the commerce
authorities need to do more in that as
well
after wimbledon decided to ban russian
tennis players it is the proms that now
has this debate daily telegraph
reporting that the bbc is to allow
russian musicians to appear at the proms
provided they have publicly or privately
voiced opposition to the invasion of
ukraine if they plan to return home to
russia anytime soon that will be very
tricky for them harry
yeah of course we will and again we get
into this sort of um who does you know
who is the moral arbiter on these things
and who appoints the who appoints the
judges on these facts if you take the
wimbledon for example lots of
russian-born tennis players you know now
live you know long successful lives in
other countries they are as critical as
uh of um
of putin's invasion as as many others
there's that famous shot i can't
remember the name of the tennis player
but the guy who wrote on the camera
while appearing at a tennis match no war
and they've been sort of blanket banned
from from sporting events and it does
seem to me like the problems are trying
to take
a slightly more nuanced approach to that
in that you can come and perform if you
you know sort of publicly denounce
um your your allegiances to your country
again i'm not sure let's see if it works
but it does just sit slightly
uncomfortably with me that we're getting
into a sort of uh
it's not it's not it's not a comfortable
place for anyone to be in when we're
sort of demanding people swear filthy to
uh to one calls or another before being
allowed to perform in the arts it's um
it's a slippery slope again i know we
keep saying that tonight
indeed so well instead there were a few
plenty more still to come we'll be
taking a look at this story on the front
of the daily telegraph which reports a
children's hepatitis outbreak linked to
lockdown or the effects of lockdown at
least back in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now are the political
editors of the sun in the mirror harry
cole and pepper cruel welcome back to
both of you um let's go to the guardian
shall we this idea of getting civil
servants back to work um the guardian is
suggesting that the uk's top civil
servant has privately warned boris
johnson against forcing government
workers back to the office amid growing
anger tell us more harry
yeah an interesting one this one because
the prime minister very clearly today
came out and said
he's back he's backing all initiatives
uh to
get people back civil servants in
whitehall back to the office now they
published some figures the other day
that's ranged from 70 of the mod back
down to just 25
of officials are back working in
whitehall in the department of education
now that will stick in the claw i think
for quite a few teachers around this
country who have been battling through
the classroom risking their times their
own health uh by keeping schools open
and uh
throughout this pandemic and actually
lots of civil servants are back at home
now the government are very keen to
you know some elements of government it
feels a little bit like it's a new front
on the sort of culture war that they're
making this work from home thing a bit
of a a driving mission for them for the
reese mogs of this world by the end of
the day actually the ministers privately
say look we are there is no there is a
direct correlation
between the departments that have been
the most uh hit in the scandal and
headlines for all the wrong reasons over
the last few months taking the home
office for example or the foreign office
if you think back the afghanistan bungle
um those are the ones that have some
amongst the lowest rates of civil
servants back in the office and the
departments have been ticking along
quite well actually have much better
rates of people back now look there is
obviously going to be a change post
pandemic that there could be more
flexible working but 75 percent of the
office not being back you begin to
wonder that's
yeah you can i begin to have a little
bit of sympathy for those saying
actually we're not firing on all
cylinders yes and in fact the times is
just in it it kind of relates um in the
suggestion that summer holidays are at
risk this paper says as the passport
office struggles to deal with a huge
surge in demand for new passports um a
lot of businesses are struggling because
people are off with kovid so it's still
it's still kind of going on if you're
back in the office so that's one of the
issues i've also got the daily mailing
as well uh in fact let's just show you
that uh that gps is set to vote at a
medical conference on whether to reduce
their surgery opening hours suggesting
it could be to 5 pm it's a far cry from
what jeremy hunt wanted isn't it of uh
you know open all hours effectively um
but let's go to our final story which
relates to health too it's in the
telegraph this idea of hepatitis and a
specific type of virus which may be
causing it
which children were less exposed to i
guess pippa
yeah it's really worrying this isn't it
i mean it's one of the um it's a case
that the uk hsa is looking into
the health security agency and
suggesting that one of the factors might
be um the fact that children young
children and it's is generally under
fives didn't come into contact with
other kids and therefore with sort of
common viruses as as they might have
done uh normally uh during during the
periods of lockdown and even sort of
either side of the lockdown periods um
social distancing when someone was in
place so obviously not for very young
children that was it would be impossible
to enforce as any parent knows but the
concern is that these kids weren't
exposed to
as much of this these adenoviruses
they're called uh which three quarters
of these cases of hepatitis 114 so far
in the country amongst children of that
age group
are linked to and um you know it's
really worrying 10 kids in the uk have
required liver transplants as results
and while the majority recover
um the there are clearly some children
that are extremely ill
they made it very clear that this is
nothing to do with um the coronavirus
vaccine obviously children of that age
group haven't had the vaccine yet anyway
um but it does look like that it's one
of these these unexplained
and and really rather worrying uh
impacts of lockdown that we at the time
um obviously the decision was made for
all the right reasons and all the right
motivations but beyond the sort of the
widely accepted fallout on on
what they understood fallout on
children's mental health um and sort of
physical health this is a very specific
example of a potentially very dangerous
um disease hepatitis which is affecting
young children and i think a lot of
parents will be would be really worried
about yeah absolutely even though the
figures as we said are still
fairly low aren't they as you said 114
cases of this acute hepatitis of unknown
origin as they describe it thank you
both very much indeed great to have you
on thank you